in the division story we're introduced
to the quarantine zones as an initiative
put forward by the government as a way
to stop the spread of the virus in New
York the whole of Manhattan was shut
down walled off as a place to hold the
sick and get them the help they needed
however once the virus landed in
Washington DC things were handled a
little differently
[Music]
you
several months after the initial
outbreak in New York City most of the
virus had burnt itself out and a
potential cure was developed by
virologists at Ann Arbor Medical School
using the research conducted by dr.
candle the first samples of this cure
was shipped to Washington DC as a
continuity of government measure however
before it was manufactured into the
large enough quantities to administer to
the public the federal government
launched a chemical named DC 62 into
highly infected areas their aim was to
destroy any remaining traces of the
virus and to sterilize the contaminated
areas unfortunately it turned out that
DC 62 not only destroyed the virus but
was also extremely toxic even to the
point of just standing within close
proximity who would cause lethal burns
and death from breathing toxic fumes I'm
not going to go into any further detail
on the DC 62 chemical as I've already
covered this in a recent video so I'll
place a completely subtle plug to that
video now sick of that pesky dollar flu
infecting and killing your loved ones
had enough of eating your family pets
rather than running the risk of getting
sick on the way to the local store that
we have the solution for you DZ 62 for
this one-time offer you too can get the
cure-all for everything viral including
the doll flu a quick spray of DZ 62 will
guarantee that nothing survives please
note the methods of our seductions of DZ
62 the circled you your family your pets
your friends your neighbors basically
anything into life the best results used
as directed but to be honest it really
does matter as we sprang straight you
neighborhood soon
located in Georgetown this area was
known for being the home of the
wealthier residents of DC when the
dollar flew hit the city the residents
of Georgetown got together to find a way
to protect themselves from what was
quickly spreading across the country led
by Victor Tran the residents used their
money and influence to pressure the
government into erecting a wall around
the entire Georgetown district unlike
New York these walls had to salt purpose
of keeping the sick out Victor Tran was
a professor of sociology at Georgetown
University for over 15 years
he is a highly respected member of the
community and has a good reputation
among his students and peers Tran is
very outspoken about societal issues
particularly when they impact Georgetown
while he doesn't have any political
aspirations the locals regard him as a
key figure hid within the community
Tryon comes across as modest and caring
however he'll always put his personal
interest at the forefront of the
decision-making he likes to be in
control and often reacts with hostility
when people disagree with them but the
walls they didn't really work
there was always someone's family member
or close relative who needed to be lived
in so eventually the dollar flew found
its way inside
Victor was forced to tighten up the
rules and anyone with the slightest
possibility of being affected was thrown
out of the district he also started
talking to the residents about a new
experimental chemical that would
eradicate the green poison for good he
went on to rally the citizens of
Georgetown to push the government into
using it around their homes first but
not everyone thought this was a good
idea Georgetown choice now we face a new
set of challenges
we will never be truly safe so we can
prevent the spread of green poison DCCC
to is our best option
but this is not up to me he's right
to do will save us that's [ __ ] and
you know it you're willing to risk the
lives of everyone in Georgetown DC 62 no
one knows what that [ __ ] is or what it
will do
Shea you're fear-mongering isn't fooling
it it's not fear-mongering
if it's the truth the truth the truth is
we need to evacuate the infected from
Georgetown if we let them stay the
disease will spread there's a Sarah camp
on the other side of the wall they are
better equipped to treat infected people
like Jess I'm not infected
she's already compromised our safety
with the wild accusations we can't let
her compromise our health Shea
Montgomery was a pre-med student at
Georgetown University she was
politically active and would frequently
arrange demonstrations on campus
regarding environmental and social
issues shares known for honesty and
always stands by her convictions
especially if she believes she's right
although she's popular among her social
circle her friends and family can get
frustrated by your attitude let's get
one thing straight I got kicked out of
Georgetown the neighborhood not the
school was running a 3.93 as a pre-med
major thank you very much
under [ __ ] pretenses it was when I
decided that maybe I could do some good
with whatever training I had out in the
real world there's my guys trouble you
see but he'd got a wall around G town to
try to keep him fight two people out but
that worked about as well as you'd think
there was always someone's cousin who
had to be let in or somebody's coworker
and free knew it we had our own cases of
green poison that's what Victor Tran
came in professor Tran was a big deal in
neighborhood politics and it didn't take
much for him to convince people that the
right thing to do was evict the patients
and spray the neighborhood he would make
all of them safe he promised now I knew
this was [ __ ] they hadn't had any
time to run to us on this D c62 stuff he
was talking about and I said so
loudly and that's when mr. Tran lied he
told people I was sick to which I wasn't
at least not yet
he had me kicked out with the rest of
the infected sentence to the Sira camp
down by the river and sprayed his DC 62i
here it killed him justice she works on
funny ways Shay was removed from
Georgetown officially this was because
she was evicted but in reality it was
because she disagreed with Tron some of
the residents knew this but in fear have
also been thrown out into the other side
of the wall hell I could even applaud
him for that but the tactics is using
flushing anyone who might be sick out of
Georgetown blowing us off so that the
infected refugees don't get in their
inhumane the worst part is there's
dozens of folks who agree with me who
won't stand up to Victor they're too
afraid of getting called out or exiled
to do with the rest of the district
degree try and push forward with having
the JTF fumigate the entire neighborhood
with DC 62 they want something they're
gonna get it no matter what
so when word came down they were looking
for a test bed for DC 62 some of the
rich folks got it in their heads that
they wanted it first what is why I'm
here in Georgetown setting up the
blower's so we can code entire houses
right past it wasn't a tool the JTF had
covered the whole area that they
realized the true effects of the
chemical immediately the people of
Georgetown started suffering from
respiratory complications and dying
shortly after there were mass casualties
and within a moment that became a ghost
town the JTF declared the area
contaminated and locked the wolves to
stop anyone from getting in from here on
the once wealthy suburb of Georgetown
was known as dark zone west
shei along with the affected residents
of georgetown however even though she
entered the compound healthy it wasn't
long and so many of us died I wasn't
sick when I got to the camp that changed
soon enough I'm one of the rare ones
though I survived Green poison it was
close I almost didn't
but thanks for some good people who took
care of me when I was at my worst I made
it through they're all gone though every
last one of them
I tell you their names but what's the
point thank God Shay was one of the
lucky ones one of the lucky few who
managed to overcome the virus once she
had managed to gain his strength she
inquired about leaving but quickly found
that the JTF guarding the camp later
known as the true sons beretta orders to
keep everyone contained regardless Shay
found a way out and she lifts with a new
purpose in life having survived the
dollar flew her goals to help as many of
the struggling residents of DC that she
could and what happened to Victor Tran
Tran could be found dead in dark zone
west
he's been strung up hanging from a
bridge rumor has it he was murdered by
Georgetown residents as a revenge for
him persuading them to accept DC 62
dooming them all
during the initial dollar flu outbreak
the military occupied an area above
Capitol Hill it was used as a staging
ground and a storage zone for food water
medical supplies and we're talking one
metric [ __ ] ton of that yellow powder
stuff the DC 62 I hear that didn't work
so good in Georgetown and if it didn't
work so good there you know I gotta
wonder why they shipping it here maybe
they don't got anywhere else to put it
after the events in Georgetown there was
an explosion at a containment storage
facility that was holding a large
stockpile of DC 62 large clouds of the
chemical was spread over the area they
were massive casualties
however evacuation of the military
personnel in the area to stop the spread
of the chemical the zone around the
explosion was quickly walled off the
military moved their staging ground
further south towards the waterfront
there was a family I found hiding out in
an apartment off Dupont Circle the
father nearly shot me but he was shaking
so badly from the disease he couldn't
hold the gun straight his wife and his
daughter were showing symptoms yet but
it's just a matter of time the way
things were going got the father meds
but made his passing easier sat with
them until he was gone got in fresh
water and by some miracle when they
didn't get sick I left them with a stash
of meds and a way to get hold of me if
they needed me I could tell that story
about 20 different families around the
city and all those stories would be true
I'm not bragging I'm asking you what
you're doing to make a difference and if
you're just surviving to think about
doing a shake continues on with their
mission of helping people around DC who
have been forgotten she spends her time
scavenging the streets for anything that
could be useful
bottled water food medicine she even
started venturing into places that
others were too scared to enter and her
eyes it was dangerous but with the risk
a capitulation dark zone is the easiest
of them to crack there was a DC 16 burst
but everyone in the zone was military or
Sarah they knew how to handle an
evacuation unlike that port idiot tram
so they packed up everyone and
everything they could get their hands on
and got the hell out of it before the
powder had a chance to settle good work
if you ask me the thing though whether
they got everyone out so fast they left
plenty of stuff behind I'm told there's
a fortune in laundry hardware just
sitting there waiting for someone to
pick up not me though I wouldn't know
what to do what half of it I'm more
interested in what got left at the field
hospital there's still Mets they're
still sterile equipment and surgical
supplies hell there's even clean toilet
paper I've been in there three times and
haven't come close to cleaning it out I
worry I'm getting predictable but so far
it's been worth the risk
the area below whis station on the
waterfront was originally the primary
storage facility for dc2 after the
explosion of the military moved to the
site after relocating the massive flood
swept through the lockdown storage
facilities containing the DC 62 the
contaminant spilled out into the flood
waters spreading all around the
waterfront contaminating the whole area
the JTF will once again forced to leave
they didn't waste any time by now they
had seen the effects of this toxin had
on people and a rush to put as much
space between them and DC 62 they left
behind a vast amount of contaminated
high-end weapons again but before
completely abandoning the area they
built another wall to keep people out
and renamed it duct so himself back to
the camp today for the first time it's a
dark zone now abandoned and lopped off
haunted hard to believe in the world
we're living in now people still have
time to be troubled by made-up things
like ghosts getting into the camp wasn't
that hard someone had put in overtime
cleaning it up from my days there he'd
never know thousands of people had died
it's not to say it was clean just that
there was no evidence of what had gone
before it just looked like a regular old
supply dump abandoned to the rats
there's a little bit I could use so I
took it but the whole time I was there I
kept waiting for it to hit me and it
never did it's like that piece of my
past is walled off now there's too much
to do now that I can't afford to think
about that
[ __ ] God DC 62 on my shoes don't have to
come off now the first time though won't
be the last
where the dark zone and New York came to
be with the intentions of grouping the
infected into an area to stop the spread
and to provide them with the help they
needed the reasons behind DC's dark
zones were very different they arose
because of the rushed release of the
improperly tested DC 60 to the
devastation in DC may have started with
the spreading of the dollar flu virus
but it was through a man-made toxin that
the city was brought to its knees
leaving thousands more dead and large
suburbs that were now completely
uninhabitable this led to further stress
on the military's resources in a time
when hostile factions were on the rise
like most of my videos I didn't start
out planning to talk about this topic
but as per usual I kept reading down the
path and I just couldn't put it back
down this was way more interesting video
I hope you enjoyed it but either way
thank you very much for watching Birds
gunshots so maybe not everything has
changed I remember a party junior year
Georgetown a bunch of us just hanging
out and drinking beer is talking about
what we're gonna do with our lives I
mean while pre-med so it's kind of a
limited conversation but even so none of
us imagined this I don't even know if
anyone else who was at that party is
still alive and yet Here I am about to
breach the Capitol Station dark zone
again looking for meds for the people
who've fallen through the cracks of
whatever systems left
I like to think I'm doing the right
thing